After I got to a certain point, I said, "There's no denying it."
I am definitely a collector.
My name is Linda Guillory.
I'm 51 years old.
I'm from North Texas...
...and I have the largest collection of vintage video gaming systems in the world.
So, my husband Tom did pass away in May of this year.
How I knew it was true love was the fact that...
...Tom did not care about video games and I still loved him.
He never played one video game in his life, but I loved Tom more than I love video games.
I've collected 3,000 games.
I have so many favorite games:...
...the Coleco tabletop series,...
...King Kong tabletop,...
...any sports, handheld,...
...Legend of Zelda.
We definitely all grieve in different ways.
Gaming systems definitely bring me a sense of nostalgia.
I feel that warmth.
It's just joy.